get in get in get in yes oh [ __ ] what
was that noise hello welcome to random
candor the live streaming show every
thursday at 11am pacific which would now
mean 6 p.m. in the UK and ireland today
we are playing probably archery its most
likely archery but I'll be honest I
don't really know because I've
intentionally not played it because I've
heard that much like surgeon simulator
this one is a little bit weird with the
control scheme ok oh Jesus so I'm moving
this with my left my with the mouse I
feel like this is not the way a wrist
should work I feel like maybe it's whoa
what ok he's got an arrow will put the
arrow in the thing and then drop the
arrow perfect i got an achievement i'm
winning at this video game ready so left
mouse button is grabbing release to
knock the arrow it's the right mouse
button and knock and put it close and
then knock and too far for your string
alright its string i got this mom there
you go there you go ok so if i hold the
shift button i move the right arm and if
you hold it moves as l Bowie this is so
specific ok also I believe the string is
currently going through my arm just kind
of terrifying ok see the problem is here
I don't know how to do real archery nock
the arrow how is that too far it's this
epic music is in stark contrast to write
bility to do this simple task yeah
here's the elbow pumping it up maybe
yeah yes I am the best partner oh Jesus
Christ it's taking me like two minutes
to get the thing in the thing okay yeah
yeah I just run up and stab the targets
instead here we go
watch it okay what I have to do I've to
release I'm so terrified to take my
finger off any of the buttons right now
ah [ __ ] chef okay we're okay whoa what's
going on there no that's not right okay
all right there there there I'm guessing
what I have to do is release the left
mouse button so here we go oh yes oh my
gosh i'm doing right this is I'm doing
my degeneration X this is my impression
of X puck hey yeah i think i'm throwing
off an archery to play this video game
against real apples okay right I don't
know this about archery culture
apparently what you do is you got your
hunky male model friends who has an
apple for a heads to put an apple on top
of his head after he's gotten rip [ __ ]
on cider here we go okay if I was this
apple man I would not be too jazzed
about what's happening here God that
Apple is so small i'm sure if i can hit
the green one let alone the one in his
head okay i'm sorry i'll tell your wife
you love her mmm there no this must be
excruciating for him
oh it definitely murdered him change my
dude named dunno and the arse face
obviously a fishbowl we got the Giant
Bomb logo okay what CBS make this game
let's do that then what else we got
robot arms I can't choose the race of my
robot this game is so racist oh how long
have to play this cave is this is the
first game mode I'm already losing the
gutter mind just changing the angle down
a bit more how about that and that oh
for God's sake this all right next one I
want to see what the Berserker is oh
Jesus Christ is running right towards me
oh my gosh ah give me an arrow at no no
pickup oh this was there hahaha look I'm
did hahahaha all right I can do this so
I have to get it up there quick straight
elbow give me an arrow naka sh there no
get in the [ __ ] thing like ok they're
right get an arrow put it in quick bend
your [ __ ] it do it there oh I forgot
to bend get in get in get in yes oh [ __ ]
ok and and yes die [ __ ] yeah
another one oh no that way god this is
so intense y'all get in it was in a
second ago there
uh-huh oh you so much closed at this
time all right get it in it why are they
still alive than the bottom this is
terrifying oh no oh good I got a bit
distance this time he's got something
else in his hand though I'm no fool i'm
waiting till he gets nice up and close
he's got a shield artists is [ __ ] ah
oh oh not as two of them oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna get one of them here all right
okay I have to take the plunge on one of
you guys oh well I'm fugs warband oh oh
oh great is this just like Berserker
mode but the dozens of people Apple man
I think that's exactly what it is Oh
what the hell you put see what you do
everybody put the arm out and then you
twist it yeah you got it yeah I know
they're getting close don't worry about
it I'm teaching you then you get the
thing and it's called knocking the arrow
you put it on the street yet exactly
hold it exactly like I'm doing it and
then and then you go you pull the string
back you let go of shift and then you go
what yeah that's right we all aim at the
same guy great we got one of them
BAM apples for dinner tonight boys okay
I meant yeah and then do it again nailed
it great this guy got through oh my god
this is literally a dream come true I've
wanted to do this my entire life okay I
have to hit the egg without hitting all
the wonderful crockery huh yes look at
prior Matt this no don't hit the oh [ __ ]
all right nock the arrow yeah nailed it
oh he did he hit the table oh [ __ ] I got
this mr. manager I'm sorry I've only
killed one of the Haunted egg things
please stop talking my pay come here
flying egg I'm almost bankrupt Oh next
mode the noose oh I think I can guess
what this is Jesus Christ even if I
managed to save it he's just gonna get
murdered by those guys anyway so why
should I bother should not just let him
die yeah it looks like it whoops nock
the arrow nock the arrow nocked ah there
perfect ah oh and your dad sorry sorry
so I balloon boy
oh you're kidding me hahahaha just put
him out of his misery sorry dude oh oh
the law of averages means at least you
know if you do this for at least two
hours i'll probably got one of them
right yeah two hours or even need two
errors on the best 0g if gold complete
zero gee I don't even okay why is there
man running towards me as well this is
not fair how is he this is deeply
confusing to the scientist inside of me
I will say it is a nice touch that he is
not screaming though because there is no
sound in space this guy would want to
get the hell out of the way though is
there another one I just play with his
dead body for a while yeah I can all
right you know up before we all my dive
into one of these again in a second well
I check out zombie soccer because this
had you not hit this button over here
yeah all right what I got to do this is
a based cricket bat I'm already confused
as to what zombie soccer could be there
is no goals oh Jesus Christ all right
all right I got it am I supposed to hit
kill the zombies with the ball stop what
this is die die just tap it in tip a
tapper the problem with Arsenal is they
try and walk the ball into the goal
maybe they should play zombies get in
probably archery all right let's check
out where you can buy this video game I
believe it is currently available on
Steam com oh alright seems being a [ __ ]
but it is it is nine pan nine dollars 99
cents which is probably i'm gonna say
around six ninety-nine in brit pans and
Queenie pennies however if you go to
indiegogo com there is a
a bundle running at the moment and you
can pick it up for four bucks including
a bunch of other games including Supreme
Commander